quel bilan pour l'indice de réparabilité
2 ans après sa création et ce qu'il a
fait évoluer les comportements des
consommateurs mais aussi des fabricants
bonjour quentingeker bonjour merci
d'être là avec nous vous êtes le
président de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée c'est indice
vous connaissez bien puisque vous avez
œuvrer sa création au côté de l'État et
de tous les acteurs d'ailleurs concernés
il faut le dire quel bilan on peut en
tirer déjà côté distributeur est-ce que
tout le monde joue le jeu ou pas
vraiment bah justement c'est une très
bonne question on a rendu un rapport en
octobre dernier pour montrer enfin pour
justement savoir si les fabricants
jouaient ou pas le jeu et cette enquête
compléter une enquête de la DGCCRF qui
avait qui a eu été rendu le 27 septembre
dernier et qui montre que non
50% des distributeurs affichés pas
l'indice de réparabilité à date donc en
septembre nous on a montré en octobre
qu'on était même encore plus haut sur
les sur les distributeurs qu'on avait
contrôlé on était autour de 60% sur les
catégories des produits qui étaient à
leur en vigueur du coup c'était
smartphone ordinateur
lave-linge hublot et j'en oublie
toujours un
quel en tout cas les étiquettes voilà ne
sont pas suffisamment loin de là affiché
dans les rayons pourtant les vendeurs
ont l'obligation les distributeurs de
retirer les produits depuis janvier 2021
et depuis un an j'en ai 2022 il s'expose
même à des sanctions de la part de la
répression des fraudes et dans les faits
il y a pas évidemment bah alors pour
l'instant nous on n'a pas connaissance
d'un an qui ont été infligés pourtant
bah oui elle s'expose à des amendes 3000
euros pour une personne physique 15000
euros si c'est une personne morale
d'ailleurs on a ça reste très théorique
je veux dire pour l'instant oui c'était
vrai mais justement nous ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on veut faire c'est que c'est
d'appeler à la responsabilité de ce
distributeurs c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
une action coup de poing en novembre
dernier à l'entrée en vigueur sur les
nouvelles sur les nouvelles catégories
de produits pour dire que c'est pas
possible ça suffit pas qu'il faut aller
plus loin et si cette responsabilité
collective des distributeurs des
vendeurs en fait sur qui sur qui pèse
sur lesquels on veut alerter en tout cas
il faudrait que la répression des fautes
façon boulot aussi qu'elle fasse
appliquer la loi effectivement c'est
notre appel c'est qu'on veut que la
DGCCRF renforce ses contrôles pour créer
un effet de mouvement en fait que
derrière les vendeurs se disent ah bah
oui on peut pas être un puni pour ça
c'est une vraie obligation qui pèse sur
nous même si c'est nouveau même si on a
des excuses bah en fait c'est la loi il
faut la respecter ça c'est ce qu'on veut
après distributeur et fabricant se
renvoie un petit peu la balle sur les
responsabilités non effectivement il y a
pas d'enquête pour le moment qui montre
que la faute incombe particulièrement
fabriquant ou particulièrement dissé par
en fait l'enquête de la DGCCRF qui a été
menée et notre enquête à nous a montré
que ça pouvait être à la fois affiché
sur le site des fabricants mais pas chez
les distributeurs des fois chez les
distributeurs mais pas chez les
fabricants donc en fait il y a un
gloubi-boulgal là dedans et on veut
faire en sorte de d'éclaircir la
situation en appelant en fait la
responsabilité collective peu importe
que la que ce soit la faute du fabricant
à ce stade ou du vendeur quel rôle aussi
est là pour le coup pour les pouvoirs
publics l'état évidemment un rôle à
jouer lors du Forum de la durabilité en
novembre dernier Bérengère Couillard la
ministre la secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'écologie a annoncé justement à qu'une
enquête nationale allait être menée
merci de m'avoir un peu sifflet sifflé
le mot c'est exactement ce qui s'est ce
qui s'est passé alors maintenant à ce
stade on n'a pas à de plus d'éléments
sur ce que va comporter cette enquête
nationale en tout cas nous on veillera à
ce que cette enquête soit une réelle
avancée une réelle poussée et pour
savoir si à la fin c'est du lard ou du
cochon savoir si c'était un effet
d'annonce et qu'à la fin c'est juste un
coup de fil à la déchets CRF aussi y
avoir des ressources supplémentaires
pour le contrôle le lundi on a parlé des
distributeurs il faut parler des
fabricants et comment est-ce qu'il note
est-ce qu'il note correctement leurs
produits parce que on en vient au choix
des critères évidemment pour établir ces
notes il y a cinq critères tout ce
valent or certains critères et je vous
laisse parler sont plus importants que
d'autres ce qu'on a montré c'est qu'en
général les fabricants c'est sur note de
on se dit qu'on ça devient vite et que
des fois elles ont une grille de
critères à respecter quand même donc
elles sont quand même restent elles sont
critères c'est ça elles sont contraintes
sous cette grille qu'elle doivent
publier mais c'est une synthèse en fait
et donc du coup il y a des marges
d'interprétation qui permettent pas de
dire si oui ou non à la fin on était sur
une une note voilà qui était on était à
7 en fait on est à 8 sauf que dans le
comportement du consommateur c'est c'est
très c'est très différent d'avoir cette
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que l'indice il
est perfectible aujourd'hui il est il
est perfectible dans à bien des égards
notamment sur la pondération c'est pas
normal que toutes les notes par effet de
compensation puisse être plus se relever
les unes les autres je prends un exemple
la démontabilité des produits c'est
hyper important c'est le plus important
à quoi ça sert d'avoir des pièces
détachées à un prix abordable si on peut
pas sidérer vous pouvez même pas ouvrir
votre appareil sans le casser du coup et
en fait pourquoi on attribuerait du coup
une bonne note un appareil qui est même
pas démontable ce qui est possible
aujourd'hui d'être réalisé avec l'indice
de réparabilité donc nous ce qu'on a ce
qu'on veut faire c'est de faire relever
c'est il y a plusieurs options possibles
mais on veut un système de pondération
un meilleur système par exemple
la démontabilités serait une condition
sine qua non côté consommateur
maintenant cette réparabilité est-ce que
c'est devenu je me disais un vrai
critère d'achat pris en compte au début
au même titre que le prix ou que la
performance du produit alors il faut
qu'on mette à jour nos données mais
effectivement au 1er mars 2022 c'est
indice était connu d'environ 50% des
consommateurs qu'on avait interrogé et
dans trois quarts des cas pour eux
c'était un indice qui était extrêmement
utile du coup bah on montre que oui oui
il a une utilité et c'est en d'autant
plus important aujourd'hui que c'est à
l'achat et c'est d'autant plus important
aujourd'hui que le consommateur avant
aucun indice sur la réparabilité il
pouvait pas savoir si l'appareil qu'il a
acheté était réparable ou pas à moins de
se farfouiller dans des détails
techniques qui n'étaient pas accessible
au grand public et c'est ce que permet
aujourd'hui cette indice il y a l'acte
d'achat puis après il y a le moment où
l'article produit tombe en panne est-ce
que les gens aujourd'hui répare plus ou
est-ce qu'ils vont toujours se rabattre
malheureusement sur un sur un produit
neuf il y a une prise de conscience et
me dire oui mais après ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'on est à l'étape d'après au
passage à l'acte justement là il y a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire ouais
ouais on est au début là effectivement
enfin lundi j'aurais pas il monte si ce
sera réparable ou pas il y a pas encore
d'études qui peuvent montrer ils font
encore un peu de temps avant de montrer
si l'indice de réparabilité a eu un
effet sur l'ensemble des produits
concernés sur la réparation il y a ce
qu'il y a d'autres facteurs en fait qui
rentrent en ligne de compte pour savoir
si on va pouvoir réparer le prix le prix
psychologique enfin un frein
psychologique lié au prix ça coûte cher
mieux vaut acheter un neuf vous êtes
très bien renseigné effectivement il y a
un frein psychologique
30% de 50% 30% effectivement c'est l'ADN
je vais vous montrer ça que au dessus de
30% généralement le consommateur se
redirige vers un achat de neuf ou un
achat d'un nouveau produit en tout cas
c'est le cas souvent bah alors justement
si 80 78 % des Européens soit être
réparer leur produit plutôt que d'en
acheter un neuf ça c'est une étude de
remettre mais seulement dans les faits
36% le font donc on voit qu'il y a un
fossé encore qui est assez énorme et
qu'on a encore du mal à combler et
ensuite c'est indice de réparabilité on
finit là-dessus va devenir ce sera l'an
prochain l'indice de durabilité
c'est-à-dire que désormais on va tester
aussi si un produit
pas seulement s'il est réparable mais
aussi s'il est robuste et là on se dit
parce que c'est mieux que notre appareil
ne tombe pas en panne c'est bien pour le
réparer mais le mieux c'est qu'il dure
le plus longtemps possible et qui tombe
le plus tard possible en panne ouais
complètement un produit peut être
réparable mais pas durable et dans le
sens où votre produit vous pouvez le
réparer autant de fois que vous voulez
mais si derrière il y a il tombe en
panne tout le temps parce que il est pas
assez robuste parce que les pièces
c'était assez bien conçu ou parce que il
a engrangé du travail forcé ou parce
qu'il a un impact environnemental
extrêmement élevé n'est pas durable même
s'il est réparable donc ça c'est des
critères supplémentaires que je viens de
citer qui doivent rentrer en ligne de
compte et il y a un deuxième enjeu à
l'indice de réparabilité c'est
l'élévation au niveau européen ça j'y
tiens vraiment beaucoup c'est que depuis
l'indice de réparabilité au niveau
français le niveau européen c'est en
étant paré et il y a une directive
maintenant pour faire un indice de
réparabilité européen et ça c'est
l'accès à 450 millions de consommateurs
de enfin c'est l'accès de ces 50 de ces
450 millions de consommateurs à un
indice de réparabilité qui concerne
potentiellement des milliards de
produits et l'Union européenne est le
premier marché du monde et c'est là que
finit la chaîne de valeur de la plupart
des entreprises et un indice de
réparabilité assez échelle on change on
peut vraiment avoir un énorme effet
merci beaucoup donc Quentin gecker de
passer nous voir vous êtes le président
de l'association hop alt à
l'obsolescence programmée merci beaucoup
à vous
[Musique]